let's finish off my leaves so far we've
looked at a couple of different ways to
work out different volumes right we've
looked at annulus slices let's just get
back in our head how does it work when
you have a question which you approach
by annulus slices right your D diagram
you end up with each of your slices
looking something like this obviously
depending on what kind of a volume
you've got okay and then each of these
annular slices we can work out what
their dimensions are we call that a
little radius which is a function
because it can change we might call this
the big radius which is also a function
because it can change and then which you
can't see at the moment it has a
thickness right which would be Delta Y
or Delta X depending on which way you
are slicing right morning so therefore
when we take this bunch of disks this
bunch of slices we say the volume will
be equal to and then we form this summer
when you see the notation to do that
right just for the sake of illustration
let's just consider a Delta Y okay we
take a limit and why do we have to put
this in what is the significance of this
limit what does it mean in this case
it's about making all of these slices
very very very thin right so that we
don't have a bunch of slices which are
close like an approximation but slices
of infinitesimally small thinness so you
really actually get the exact volume not
approximation right so then what do we
add up do we add up well maybe I should
say where do we add up because this
thing has boundaries right well I guess
it just depends on the volume that they
they give you you're gonna have just
like an area and upper bound and lower
bound would okay right now what is the
actual thing that we're adding up what
comes in after here
it's going to be the volume of the slice
is it not okay
so we've worked out we've looked at
these annular slices before there's two
circles so we do the subtraction you get
this big circle - little circle but
that's just an area right to make it a
volume we multiplied by in this case
Delta one okay cool so that's the way we
approach it and then of course we
recognize that we can work out what this
sum is by integration okay and so we
write this equivalent integral yeah we
take that pie at the front cause it's
just the constant from A to B and then
you've got this and you're integrating
with respect to wine okay great no
problems now cylindrical shells it's
still a bit fresher in my our minds but
I hope you can see the parallel PR right
instead of getting this kind of shape
right we divide it up in a different way
this was perpendicular to the axis of
rotation so when we go parallel to the
axis of rotation that's why you get a
cylindrical shell okay it's not a
cylinder it's just a shell that's why I
used the piece of paper to illustrate
it's um there's no it's hollow that's
completely Hollow which means that if
you get if a metaphorical or a a real
pair of scissors right and you cut the
cylindrical shell you end up with just
the rectangle right and you saw it okay
so being that this is a cylinder it's
defined by two dimensions what are they
what are they on one of the dimensions
that I can know which will exhaustively
define it I need to know the radius
which in turn gives me the circumference
which will be important a second and
what's the other thing I need to know to
work out this cylindrical shell
I need the height don't I okay so when
you cut it open and you unfold it okay
this chip either goes round it becomes
this distance
yes and of course the height is still
it's still there okay so now that it's a
rectangle and just like this it has a a
depth of Delta Y or Delta X now I can
form the Sun okay so help me volume
equals okay again just for the sake of
illustration suppose we were taking the
same volume right so instead of Delta Y
I'm gonna have Delta X for this one okay
and what all of the shells to be very
very very thin I'm gonna add up again
from A to B but notice that these are X
found reasonable Y boundaries and then
what's going to happen after the Sigma
notation I put in there here it came
from the area of this times its depth so
this is gonna come from the area of this
times its Devon right which you saw
before was 2 PI R Plus u H there's the
area times its depth okay and it exactly
the same way I can go from the sum to
the equivalent integral okay we took the
2 pi out cuz it's a constant I said I've
integrated from A to B that RH you
remember just like this big R little R
they are functions ok and we want them
in this case to be in terms of X and
then we integrate off we go ok now these
are great methods they're really
fantastic you've seen we've been able to
approach a whole bunch of different and
weird volumes with these but the
hallmark of powerful mathematics is its
ability to transition smoothly between
different kinds of problems ok now these
kinds of problems that we're looking at
they're different we've been opened up
to a whole bunch of volumes but there
are only certain kinds of volumes that
you can do by these methods right every
time you get a question like this
they'll give you a function they say you
know he's a he's a is a function or
something like that ok they will give
you some boundaries
something like this okay and then what
other information must they provide to
you for you be able to work out the
volume you need to have an axis of
rotation right and not say here for
instance the x axis or the y axis or
something like that okay my point is
though but there must be some rotation
you can only work out solids of
revolution by these methods okay because
they're round shapes maybe if you don't
have something round you can't use
either of these okay but we can take
these same approaches right and these
are very specific to solids of
revolution and we can generalize to work
out things that haven't been found by
rotation okay stay with me if you
haven't written this down you should
because I'm gonna refer to a couple of
things on this right can you tell me
what's in common between these
approaches what's in common you think
about what's different and that'll help
you see what's in common okay what do
you need to know I think that there are
three ingredients that go into both of
these which are generalized okay for
instance I've got this component okay
can you see that component it's going to
be the same whether you're doing a pie
slices or buy shells what does it
signify that Delta Y what is it about
it's about thickness it's a [ __ ] or
thinness I suppose as Apple has made
people used to say my phone is one
centimeter thick but now Apple has made
forced everyone to say it's five
millimeters thin anyway now it's the
same idea how are you gonna cut this
thing up and obviously I can cut it up a
different way if I like okay and in fact
you know these are y's and x's but do
you remember I showed you this one I
think we took the hyperbola right and
then I rotated around this right and
then I think we call we call this axis
like H axis or something like that
okay and then it's the place of these we
had Delta H's so in other words number
one you need to know how do we cut this
thing up
okay in what way am I going to break
this into pieces okay number two when I
break it into pieces what's the size
volume of each of the pieces going to be
okay where is that on each of these
lines where is it new color um surely
it's the function isn't it it's the
function in this case this there's my
annular disc okay and here this is my
unfurled cylindrical shell okay so
number two what I need to know is um how
big are the pieces okay and they have to
be related in some way these pieces okay
I mean in this case they're all idealist
slices in this case or cylindrical
shells but they follow the same rules
that's the important part
okay what's the last piece that goes
into this the third and last piece it's
gonna be your boundaries right how would
you articulate that I guess you would
say you know how do we cut how big of
the pieces and then you know how far is
this shape going okay one of what things
bounded right so you can know well I'm
gonna go this far I'm gonna go this far
or whatever okay so if I can find any
kind of volume for which I can work out
how do we cut Kenna is there such a way
that I can cut it then I'm gonna get
something where they're all unified in
by some sort of characters these those
pieces and that share those countries
how big are they and then how far do I
have to go okay if you can get something
which matches all of those you'll be
right you can work out a volume okay